THANK YOU.
ERIC.
ERIC:  THE BATTLE BREWING OVER
THE COVID MANDATES, IT COULD
FINALLY END UP BEING DECIDED IN
COURT.
THE ADMINISTRATION SAYS MASS
VACCINATIONS WILL HELP FINALLY
GET COVID UNDER CONTROL.
HERE’S THE SURGEON GENERAL.
>> THE DATA TELLS US THESE
REQUIREMENTS WORK TO INCREASE
VACCINATIONS.
NUMBER TWO, A LOT OF BUSINESSES
ARE ACTUALLY RELIEVED THAT THESE
ARE GOING INTO PLACE.
THIS IS WHAT WE’VE GOT TO DO TO
GET TO THE NEXT PHASE OF THE PAN
PANDEMIC RESPONSE SO WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS AND GET BACK TO
NORMAL ONCE AND FOR ALL.
ERIC:  THE FORMER DIRECTOR FOR
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL,
DR. TOM FREEDMAN JOINS US NOW.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> NICE TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
ERIC:  DO YOU THINK THE MANDATES
ARE NECESSARY?
>> WELL, BOTTOM LINE HERE, DELTA
IS DEADLY.
VACCINES ARE REMARKABLY EVIDENCE
EVIDENCE PARTICULAR AND MANDATES
WORK -- EFFECTIVE AND MANDATES
WORK.
NOBODY LIKES BEING TOLD WHAT TO
DO.
THE FACT IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU
GET VACCINATED DOESN’T JUST
AFFECT YOU.
IT ALSO AFFECTS PEOPLE YOU MIGHT
SPREAD COVID TO, WHETHER THAT’S
THE CHECKOUT PERSON AT THE
SUPERMARKET OR YOUR KIDS OR
TEACHERS OR A GRAND PARENT AND
IT ALSO AFFECTS PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO USE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE IN WITH COVID.
SO YES, MASK MANDATES WORK.
VACCINATION IS OUR MOST
IMPORTANT WAY TO GET PAST THIS
PANDEMIC, TO GET BACK TO WHERE
WE NEED TO BE AND FUNDAMENTALLY
WE WANT OUR KIDS TO BE IN
SCHOOL, LEARNING SAFELY.
WE WANT TO BE BACK AT WORK,
GETTING OUR JOBS BACK.
AND WE NEED TO SAVE LIVES.
ERIC:  WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
SOMEONE WATCHING RIGHT NOW,
PERHAPS, WHO HAS BEEN RELUCTANT,
EITHER FEARFUL OR ANOTHER
BELIEF, HAS BEEN RESISTANT TO
GETTING A VACCINATION?
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE QUESTIONS, HOW SERIOUS IS
COVID, HOW SAFE IS THE VACCINE?
I THINK AT THIS POINT THE DATA
IS EXTREMELY CLEAR, COVID
REMAINS DEADLY.
IN FACT, IF YOU LIVE IN FLORIDA
OR MISSISSIPPI TODAY, YOU ARE 10
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE KILLED
BY COVID IN THE COMING WEEK AS
IF YOU LIVED IN A STATE THAT HAS
SENSIBLE POLICIES TO PROTECT
YOU.
10 TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE.
THE COVID VACCINATION, IT’S NOT
SOMETHING THAT CAME ON
OVERNIGHT.
THIS IS 10, 20 YEARS OF RESEARCH
THAT WENT INTO A REALLY SUPER
TECHNOLOGY.
IT’S VERY EFFECTIVE.
I’VE GOTTEN ONE.
EVERYONE IN MY FAMILY HAS GOTTEN
FULLY VACCINATED.
AND I REALLY ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED, NOT JUST TO
PROTECT YOURSELF BUT ALSO PEOPLE
AROUND YOU, OUR ECONOMY, OUR
KIDS’ ABILITY TO LEARN, JOBS.
THIS IS A GREAT DISCOVERY.
NO CORNERS WERE CUT.
WE’VE HAD HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE VACCINATED AND SERIOUS
SIDE EFFECTS ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
RARE.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
LONG-TERM NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE
HAVE CONCERNS N, THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS, THEY’RE TIRED OF
COVID AND YES, MANY PEOPLE WHO
GET COVID AREN’T SERIOUSLY ILL
BUT FAR TOO MANY HAVE DIED.
ERIC:  A CDC STUDY SHOWS YOU
HAVE AN 11 TIMES MORE CHANCE OF
BEING HOSPITALIZED IF YOU ARE
NOT VACCINATED BY COVID AND MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM NOT HAVING
THE VACCINATION.
AND YOU MENTIONED FLORIDA, FOR
EXAMPLE.
WHY IS THE RISK OF DEATH AND OF
GETTING COVID IN FLORIDA AS YOU
JUST MENTIONED, WHY IS IT SO
HIGH?
>> AS GREAT AS VACCINES ARE AND
AS EFFECTIVE AS THE COVID
VACCINATION IS, IT’S NOT
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE ALL
ON ITS OWN.
FIRST OFF, WE NEED A MUCH HIGHER
PROPORTION OF PEOPLE VACCINATED.
SECOND, DELTA IS SO INFECTIOUS
THAT IN SOME SETTINGS WE NEED
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF PROTECTION.
THAT MEANS MASKING UP INDOORS,
INCREASING VENTILATION, TESTING,
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COVID AND TO THEIR CONTACTS
SO THAT CHAINS OF TRANSMISSION
CAN STOP.
THE VIRUS HASN’T STOPPED KILLING
PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH WE’VE GOTTEN
TIRED OF HEARING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE 18 MONTHS IT’S TIME WE
FEEL TO GO OUT AND IGNORE IT BUT
IF WE IGNORE IT, IT WILL COME
BACK TO BITE US.
ERIC:  YOU MENTIONED DELTA BEING
DEADLY.
WHAT ARE YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
NEW VARIANT THAT IS APPARENTLY
IN EVERY STATE, ALMOST EVERY
STATE, THE MU, SPELLED M-U
VARIANT, WHAT IS THAT?
HOW BAD IS IT?
ARE WE PROTECTED AGAINST THAT
WITH THE VACCINES THAT WE HAVE?
>> ONE THING AT A TIME.
DELTA IS STILL THE DOMINANT
VARIANT.
IT’S SO INFECTIOUS THAT IT’S
DIFFICULT FOR OTHER VARIANTS TO
TAKE OVER FROM IT.
SECOND, OUR VACCINES WORK
AGAINST THE VARIANTS OF OUT
THERE.
THEY MAY WORK A LITTLE LESS WELL
BUT THEY STILL WORK
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL BUT THE BIG
CONCERN IS THAT IF WE CONTINUE
TO ALLOW THIS VIRUS TO SPREAD
AROUND THE U.S. AND AROUND THE
WORLD WITHOUT BEING CONTROLLED,
THERE IS A HIGH LIKELIHOOD THAT
A FUTURE VARIANT WOULD BE EVEN
MORE DEADLY OR DANGEROUS THAN
DELTA.
THAT’S WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE INCREASE VACCINATIONS,
THAT WE HAVE A MULTILAYER WAY OF
PROTECTING SO WE TAMP DOWN
SPREAD AND THAT WE TRACK THE
VIRUS AND STAY ONE STEP AHEAD OF
IT.
ERIC:  GET THE SHOT, WEAR YOUR
MASK, IF YOU WANT TO SAVE YOUR
LIFE SAYS DR. TOM FREEDEN.